>> Tucker: PHIL KEATING IN
FLORIDA.
THANK YOU, PHIL.
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT
JOINS US TODAY.
DAN, THIS IS ALWAYS TRUE, NOT
EXACTLY WHAT WE EXPECTED.
WHEN THIS MAN IS APPREHENDED, HE
TURNS OUT TO BE A MIDDLE-AGED
MALE STRIPPER THAT IDENTIFIES AS
AN AMERICAN INDIAN.
THESE BOMBS MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN OPERATIVE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THIS
STORY?
THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW YESTERDAY?
WHAT CONCLUSIONS CAN WE DRAW
FROM THE FACT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW?
>> I CAN SAY I'VE WORKED
PROTECTIVE INTELLIGENCE CASES IN
THE SECRET SERVICE FOR MANY
YEARS WHICH OF THE CASES WE
INVESTIGATE THEIR CASES,
BASICALLY.
OUT OF THE NEW YORK OFFICE,
WHICH WAS VERY BUSY, THE PATTERN
HERE IS NOT THAT UNUSUAL.
I'VE DISCUSSED THIS ON FOX A
COUPLE OF TIMES BEFORE, TUCKER.
WHEN YOU SEE MOVIES LIKE "IN THE
LIGHT A FIRE," PEOPLE ARE
INFLUENCED BY WHAT HAPPENS IN
HOLLYWOOD, YOU SEE A TARGET
SIMILARLY FOCUSED ON ONE
SUBJECT.
WITH "TAXI DRIVER," THAT'S NOT
THE WAY IT WORKS IN THE REAL
WORLD.
WHAT YOU SEE IS PRETTY COVERED
WITH WHAT YOU SAW WITH THE
ACCUSED ATTACKER TODAY WHICH WE
CALL TARGET SHIFTING WHERE THEY
PICK MULTIPLE TARGETS AT THE
SAME TIME.
THAT'S MORE COMMON IN THE REAL
WORLD.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT'S
INDICATIVE OF A GREATER DANGER
THAN THAT ONE PERSON WHO FOCUSES
ON THE ONE -- STALKS THE ONE
PERSON.
>> Tucker: SURE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT
THAT NONE OF THESE DEVICES
EXPLODED?
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT DOESN'T
MINIMIZE THE TERROR THEY DESTROY
AND
SPEIER, IT'S HORRIFYING.
DOES IT TELL US SOMETHING THAT
THEY DIDN'T GO OFF.
WAS HE IN THE NEXT BOMB MAKER?
WHAT CAN WE CONCLUDE?
>> OLD LEAD TWO EXPLANATIONS ON
IT.
HE INTENDED THEM, AS YOU SAY TO
INSPIRE TERROR, NO LESS DEVIOUS
AS HE SAID.
BUT OBVIOUSLY LESS DEADLY.
THE SECOND EXCLAMATION NUMBER
WHICH I BELIEVE IS MORE
PLAUSIBLE IN THIS CASE, HE JUST
WAS COMPLETELY INEPT, AND THE
WORD I THINK USED IS INACCURATE.
HE WAS ENTIRE, COMPLETELY INEPT.
THE FACTS OF THIS CASE,
THANKFULLY, I SAY THAT IN A
POSITIVE WAY, THE MISTAKES IN
THIS CASE IS INCREDIBLE.
SIMPLE THE SPELLING OF NAMES TO
SEE AND THEN WHERE JOHN BRENNAN
DOESN'T EVEN WORK, THE USE OF
TAPE?
THAT'S HOW THEY GET FINGERPRINT
FINGERPRINTS.
TAPE.
THAT'S HOW POLICE OFFICERS GET
GET -- IT'S AN AMATEUR HOUR
OPERATION, I DON'T THINK HE
INTENDED THESE THINGS NOT TO GO
OFF.
I THINK HE WAS REALLY BAD AT
THIS IF THE ACCUSATIONS ARE
CORRECT.
>> Tucker: IF THIS MAN DID
WHAT HE IS ACCUSED OF DOING, THE
PROFILE IS WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT.
AGAIN, THIS IS A MAN IN HIS
MID-50s WHO IDENTIFIES AS
SEMINOLE INDIAN AND HAS WORKED
APPARENTLY FOR DECADES AS A MALE
STRIPPER.
YOU TYPICALLY THINK OF CRIMES
LIKE THIS AS BEING COMMITTED BY
YOUNG MEN.
HE'S NOT.
NEITHER WAS THE SHOOTER IN
LAS VEGAS.
ARE WE WRONG IN THINKING THAT
MASS KILLING IS TYPICALLY
INSPIRED OR CARRIED OUT BY YOUNG
PEOPLE?
>> WELL, IN THIS CASE, TUCKER, I
WOULD ATTRIBUTE A LOT OF THIS
AND I'VE SEEN THIS IN SOME OF
THE INVESTIGATIONS I HAVE
CONDUCTED WERE MAIL WAS USED TWO
NARCISSISM, IT MAY BE A PLAY
HERE.
I MEAN, EXTREME NARCISSISM.
I BE LOOKING AT THE MIRROR AND
COMING YOUR HAIR.
THESE ARE ALLEGATIONS, OF
COURSE, BUT HE WAS A STEROID
USER, OBSESSED WITH WORKING OUT.
YOU ARE THE GUY TO TURN THIS
AROUND?
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT UNCOMMON AND
TARGET SHIFTING IS IMPORTANT.
THAT WAS A BULL'S-EYE TO ME THAT
THIS PERSON WAS A BIGGER DANGER
THAN HE WAS LETTING ON IF WE HAD
FOUND EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE
TARGETING MULTIPLE PEOPLE AT THE
SAME TIME.
IT'S NOT JUST THE QUANTITY OF
PEOPLE, IT'S THE FACT THEY ARE
SO OBSESSED WITH DOING SOMETHING
THAT THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO
FOCUS ON ONE PERSON, THEY'LL GET
ANYONE.